[Musik]
auf Höhe der nordrhein-westfälischen
Stadt Kerpen wurde vor Jahren an der
Autobahn ein aufwendiges Projekt
angelegt am Straßenrand der A4 steht die
Baum des jahresallee eine hübsche Idee
allerdings funktioniert sie nicht denn
die extremen Bedingungen sind Gift für
die Pflanzen die Bäume müssen immer
wieder ersetzt werden
ja es ist ein und das von unseren
Steuergeldern bezahlt wird und das nicht
vorher mal ein Experte zu Rate gezogen
wurde der sich damit beschäftigt hat
welche Pflanzen da hätten überleben
können
normal denken Mensch sagen können dass
das nicht funktionieren kann 2014 wird
der Schnur gerade Autobahnabschnitt neu
gebaut um die Monotonie beim Autofahren
zu unterbrechen werden links und rechts
die jeweiligen Bäume des Jahres
gepflanzt aber allein 2020 müssen 78
tote Bäume ersetzt werden der Leiter des
Botanischen Gartens Bonn hält die
Bedingungen an der Autobahn für völlig
ungeeignet an dem Standort sind die den
jungen Bäume voll der Sonne exponiert
sie sind auf einem Boden der nicht
gewachsen ist der höchstwahrscheinlich
entweder stark verdichtet ist oder
unglaublich durchlässig das Wasser
sofort abbrennt und der Jungpflanze gar
nicht zur Verfügung steht das ganze
baumprojekt hat bis
980.000 Euro gekostet gebaut von Straßen
NRW ist heute die Autobahn GmbH des
Bundes zuständig hier hat man keine
Ahnung warum die Bäume ausgerechnet da
stehen wo sie stehen
die Idee die Bäume an Standorte zu
setzen wo sie nicht unbedingt die
optimalen buchsbedingungen haben ist
dann ja nicht heute nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar wie das damals geprüft
wurde trotzdem versucht die Autobahn
GmbH mit einem riesen Aufwand das
Millionengrab am Leben zu halten
immerhin demnächst soll geprüft werden
ob sich das lohnt oder das teure Projekt
lieber ganz beerdigt wird